thanks Michael yeah so if anyone does
have questions about Cornell Tech in
general I'm more than happy to answer
them it tends to be a longer
conversation than it should be
as to how it fits in with Cornell but
basically I am at Cornell and I'm also
at Cornell Tech and I live in New York
City and commute to a weird Island over
the river by cable car so that's my
average day so the high-level goal of my
work is to design and build new
technologies that help underserved
communities to overcome global
challenges which is sort of deliberately
broad and vague and when I think about
global challenges most of my work can
fall under one or another of these
sustainable development goals that were
put out by the UN in 2015 so this is a
set of 17 goals and one of the really
nice things about the sustainable
development goals is that they do not
target any particular region or country
or populations specifically they are for
all of humanity regardless of where you
live and so most of my work can be
framed around probably three or four of
these particular goals but if you don't
know what these are I encourage you to
look them up and to date most of my work
has actually been in sub-saharan Africa
and Southeast Asia or East Asia India
Bangladesh I actually grew up in
Zimbabwe and so South sub-saharan Africa
is home for me and these are sort of a
smattering of projects that I've worked
on in the last few years but today I'm
not actually going to talk about any of
my international work I'm going to talk
about some work that I've been doing
very close to a home in New York City
and this is actually the first talk that
I'll be giving on this line of work I've
been at Cornell for two years now and I
started this work shortly after I got
there so it's been a long time coming
but I'm super excited so we've been
studying the role of Technology in
intimate partner violence and I have a
wonderful set of collaborators the top
row there are oral faculty Tom Reston
part is in CS at Cornell Tech Karen levy
is in is at Cornell in Ithaca Damon
McCoy is in CS at NYU
and then our wonderful PhD students as
well so it's definitely a
interdisciplinary team effort and the
goal of this project is to really first
of all understand how technology is
being used in intimate partner violence
by abusers to hurt their victims and
then secondly to design or redesign
technology in ways that does a better
job of protecting victims so intimate
partner violence or domestic violence is
a huge societal problem and the
statistics on it are actually quite
overwhelming surveys for example this
one from the National intimate partner
and sexual violence survey suggests that
25 percent of women and 11 percent of
men will suffer rape physical violence
or stalking by an intimate partner at
some point in their lives and it's a
recurring problem so if you suffer from
this form of abuse chances are it will
happen again and again so 38 percent of
battered women will be victimized again
within six months and there's a lot of
evidence and sobering reports about the
prevalence of this problem thinking
about this in technology terms and going
to some of these big players like why
should Facebook care about this or why
should Google care about this you know
we're really talking about hundreds of
millions of people right if your
platform has a billion users and thirty
odd percent of them are going to be
suffering from this you're talking about
300 million people so it's definitely
not a small problem and so far there's
actually been really almost no work that
tries to understand the role that
technology plays there's a few different
papers and hopefully that's changing now
as we pay more attention to it but
there's really been a void of
understanding of how technology is being
used in this space so our project has
been in collaboration with the New York
City mayor's office to combat domestic
violence the OSI DV they've been a
fantastic partner and have allowed us
access to lots of their facilities and
clients and victims and professionals
across the city
we've now spoken with almost a hundred
stakeholders and victims and we have a
really cool data set
and so far we've written two papers on
this stuff so one is or was at the first
version of CS DW to be a weird journal
that looks really at the ecosystem and
how all of these different pieces are
working together and the role of
technology within that and then upcoming
we have a KY paper on just the ways that
technology is being used by abusers and
so our findings from these two papers
are going to be what I talk about mostly
today if we have time I'll talk about
some of the work we've been doing also
on the spyware measurement so we have a
measurement study that we just published
that Oakland that looks at you know what
is the spyware that's being used and how
prevalent is it and what we can do about
it and then if we have time I'll talk a
little bit about some of our future work
that's looking more into building tools
to try and actually prevent some of the
attacks that we've been seeing and that
I'll mostly talk about today just for a
little bit of background so the New York
City system runs these centers that are
called family justice centers and
there's one in every borough in New York
so five of them Manhattan Brooklyn
Queens Staten Island and the Bronx they
are essentially a one-stop-shop for
services for victims of domestic
violence and intimate partner violence
they provide services from I think 23
different organizations that provide
legal services housing services shelter
food assistance with children all these
sorts of things under one roof and so
we've been partnering with them and all
of the qualitative work that's been done
has actually been in these family
justice centers talking to people from
all of these different organizations and
also talking to the clients of these
organizations themselves who are
survivors of intimate partner violence
so it's been a year-long study we did
focus groups with clients who are the
survivors and I'll call them clients
from now on but these are people who
have experienced intimate partner
violence themselves we did a total of 11
focus groups with 39 women in both in
and Spanish and a very broad range of
demographic characteristics and
socio-economic characteristics and they
come from 15 different countries and
then we did one-on-one interviews with
50 professionals in the space and this
included NYPD attorneys case workers
social workers pretty much everyone we
could find in the ecosystem so this is
our data set and we got about 39 hours
of recordings that were translated into
over a thousand pages of interview
transcripts that we then analyzed using
thematic analysis and came up with a
bunch of different themes and codes that
I'll talk about now and just a note
before I go into some of this so some of
these stories are pretty sensitive in
terms of representing an individual
victims story and we were very careful
to try and do this work in ways that
would empower them or protect them and
protect their privacy overwhelmingly we
found that people were very happy to
talk to us about their experiences and
in part because nobody has been paying
attention to this issue so far at all
and many of them have suffered horrific
experiences when it comes to technology
and so this quote from one of the
clients that sort of says the reason
that I came today is because I'm hoping
to let people know my story maybe this
is going to help somehow to help another
person who's going through the same
thing and so we've gone through various
ethics review with IRB and with New York
City and to try and make sure that what
we're doing is actually helping and not
hurting and the clients themselves were
very excited that somebody was paying
attention to this issue okay so let's
start by looking at an example so this
is gonna be one particular client story
she said I was raised in a country in
which women are trained to serve men
I'll say that he never hit me basically
but he did the worst thing ever honestly
I would probably rather he hit me
instead of the things that he did to me
so he put spyware in our computer
obviously I didn't know because he
studied computer programming so he was
very savvy up
it he went into my computer he got my
Facebook password email password and he
shared naked pictures of me he sent them
from his Facebook to my bosses he took
my phone and he sent them through
private messages to several friends but
also through my email and my facebook
because he had my password the
embarrassment that I went through the
public humiliation it beat me to the
ground okay so there's a lot going on
and this is one story and we have lots
and lots of these types of stories I've
put in bold some of the technology
relevant attacks so this idea of putting
a spyware in our computer as you know he
has the ability to install things on
shared devices and the whole idea of our
computer our family computer gets into
questions of ownership that I'll talk
about in a second obviously there's
account compromise going on in that he
can get her Facebook password email
password and this happens in a variety
of ways both because I know that your
Facebook password is the birthday of our
child or I can force you to give me your
password by threatening to hurt you or I
can guess your security questions and
reset your password that way so there's
multiple ways that somebody with
intimate knowledge of the victim can
actually get that password there's this
issue of non-consensual intimate images
that probably all of you have heard of
sharing naked pictures revenge porn in
this case with her employers with her
friends and potentially publicly in
addition to account compromised there's
also device compromised going on in that
he can actually physically take away her
device and do things to it without her
permission so taking away the phone and
sending them to her friends and then
also impersonating the victim by
compromising these accounts and sending
images pretending to be her so in total
our KY paper talks about this in a lot
of detail we have these four different
categories of attacks so we have attacks
that are related to ownership and this
is very complicated because of the
intimate relationships involved
what does it mean if you have a family
plan who owns the family plan who owns
the accounts many of our participants
said that they would call the phone
company to try and get them to prevent
their abuser from accessing their
account only to be told that their
abuser is the legal owner of their
account and so there's really nothing
they can do
obviously account and device compromise
is a huge set of issues which gets into
physical access to the device
things like spyware being able to
remotely hack things through security
questions we also saw a lot of posting
harmful messages and posts which is an
area of attacks that is probably more
similar to some of the the more standard
harassment or abuse that has been
studied in the literature one
interesting thing we saw that at the
bottom this proxy harassment people
would often recruit a third person to
harass the victim on their behalf often
this was a new partner or somebody who
had been told lies about the victim and
so they would start getting harassment
from lots of people that they didn't
know and then exposure of private
information things like daxing blackmail
non-consensual intimate images and
mostly what we saw as the previous
example shows is that many of these
clients would experience multiple of
these things so there's huge overlap in
terms of what they're experiencing and
it's not just one particular attack
usually technology is involved in many
many different ways so we'll just go
through another story quickly this
client said I was mentally emotionally
and verbally abused I had finally had
enough and filed an order of protection
because of the social media abuse he
would hack into all my social media
accounts and post that I cheated I
wasn't allowed to have any social media
account without him having it on his
phone I would set up my password but I
would have to give it to him he asked
and said if you don't consent to this we
have to break up he was reading every
single conversation I had he was
uploading my text messages from iphone
to another
device it just automatically goes I
don't even know how it really worked it
was through iCloud because he hacked it
and changed my name and birthday and
security questions and took over my
entire account put my iphone on lost and
erased mode for email he changed all of
my passwords when I went to go log in
and reset my password a text message
would go to his phone okay so looking at
our table there's a few different things
going on here definitely being able to
post harmful information so hack into
her accounts impersonate her post that
she cheated again account compromised
this particular story brings up
something that we've called dual use
apps so dual use apps might be apps that
do have a legitimate purpose but that an
intimate partner violence contexts are
being repurposed in ways that hurt
people okay so in this case it's being
done through iCloud and by syncing all
of that iCloud data you can use that as
a surveillance tool
even though iCloud has a legitimate
purpose that is not necessarily about
trying to abuse somebody obviously the
intimate knowledge of the victim in this
case so the fact that he knows her
birthday he can answer her security
questions he can change all of this
information allows him to delete the
information erase her phone and then
lock her out of her own accounts okay so
again many of these different things
going on all at the same time and what
these stories really have in common and
a lot of these different attacks is that
the social context the relational the
complexity of these situations in IPV
really undermine all of our common
approaches to computer and digital
security okay so in computer security
you'll often talk about things like
threat models and for those of you you
might that might not know a threat model
is defined by two things one is
identifying who is the attacker and who
is the victim and then secondly looking
at the attackers capabilities and goals
in most of
the tools that we use today we see
security mechanisms that might look
something like this pin codes passwords
these are really the state of the art
that we have at the moment and
conventionally we'd like to think of
these attackers as being a random person
on the internet you don't know the
victim personally you connect from
elsewhere maybe online maybe you're
spamming someone maybe you're doing a
email scam but you're not necessarily
the person who you're sharing your
apartment with sharing your life with by
contrast in IPV the attacker is an
intimate partner who knows the victim
personally can guess or compel
disclosure of their passwords and the
information may connect from the victims
own account and own computer and own
phone and we really don't have security
mechanisms that handle this particular
use case at all all of the the username
and password based security just falls
apart in this particular situation and
feel free to interrupt me if you have
questions by the way I'm happy to to do
that so what are some of the scenarios
that are not really handled yet so one
is this issue of how do you deal with
fake accounts okay very commonly we
would see that people would set up fake
accounts and we have this counselor here
that said a lot of fake Facebook
profiles very obviously belong to the
abuser but the survivors have no way to
prove that it's the abuser doing it
often it's because that person writes
them a message when you can do when
you're not friends with someone on
Facebook okay so dealing with these fake
accounts an abuser will set up an
account that has a fake name and
immediately post harassing messages to
the victim the victim knows that it's
coming from the abuser but whatever the
fake account name is is who it appears
to be coming from and if you contact
Facebook they have no way to actually
prove who owns that fake account and get
it taken down so our ability or the
companies and technology company's
ability to deal with these sorts of
threats is also not really serving the
needs of this particular
clientele another one is trying to
detect this abuse of content in the
first place and this is often because
abusers will post coded threats so
things that might not look threatening
to a third party but that are extremely
threatening to the victim so this
attorney said the abuser will post
something on Facebook
sometimes in code language they'll say
things that they know is a threat but
you might not think it's a threat at
first if you're just looking at it and
the complication here is that many of
the models that these companies use is
that you report abuse they will go and
look at that content they will then
decide if they agree that it's abuse and
if it is abuse they will take it down in
these scenarios much of the stuff does
not appear to be abusive because it's
based on this coded threat for example
I'm holding your child in a way that I
know you won't like or at a location
that you didn't know your child was
there to the person looking at the post
it's just a man holding a child to you
it's very threatening but you can't get
that taken down because it's not
explicitly a death threat or some
harmful image another complication is
that obvious solutions are not easy to
pursue so overwhelmingly what we saw was
that the professionals in this space the
NYPD in particular but also social
workers would just recommend that the
victims go and throw away their device
throw away your phone delete all of your
accounts delete your online banking just
get out okay this is actually not
feasible for most of the victims so you
might think okay let's just shut off
contact with the abuser let's just give
them new devices and let's just get off
social media so that you don't face
these threats okay these things don't
actually work because often you can't
shut off contact with that abuser
especially in cases of shared custody
for example you might be legally
required to communicate with that person
because you share a child in common
forgetting new devices often the abuser
is the one who has financial control of
the relationship
the victim has often stayed at home does
not have any money has been locked out
of the family's finances so they don't
actually have money to buy a new phone
the abuser could also give the children
devices which we saw quite a lot and I
think I have an example of that coming
up but in these cases even if the client
does not have any communication with the
abuser if the abuser gives that child a
phone because they want to give them a
phone for their birthday that phone can
then be used to provide the abuser with
insight into the victims life even
though it's not something that she
consented to and then this idea that you
can just shut down all of your social
media accounts the social context of
helping victims of intimate partner
violence really shows that this social
connections to people who love you and
can support you is very important for
trying to deal with this particular kind
of harm and so cutting yourself off from
your social circles is just not going to
help and for a lot of these victims
their family is also in another country
so they've come here from a country and
they need to communicate with their
family back home and if they shut down
all of these accounts they're losing
that crucial social support another
really big challenge is the idea of
escalation
okay and by this we mean that the abuse
severity will increase when the abuser
loses some kind of power that he has
over the victim
so this social worker says clients are
much more at risk when they actually
separate from their abusers because he
suddenly no longer has any control over
that victim so often the only thing left
is through the phone he's gonna start
harassing you calling texting if you
change your number now he's likely gonna
go crazy so that's when he's gonna start
stalking you any way he can
okay and this brings up a really
interesting dynamic which is that we saw
that many victims actually want to
maintain communication with their abuser
so that they could understand the state
of mind of that abuser and understand
how likely it was that he's going to
show up on their doorstep
in the middle of the night and start
beating down the door okay often that
limited amount of communication was
enough to sort of keep them at bay
keep them physically away from the
client okay so it's a somewhat
counterintuitive idea but it really felt
the victims felt that they had control
if they were able to maintain that
limited communication with an abuser
this idea that came up again and again
and again of hacking we found really
interesting as computer scientists the
word hack comes up a lot in our data and
we actually came up with this really
great code word that's called magical
hacking which sort of describes anything
that these participants would put down
too we don't know what's going on it
must be magical technology hacking they
somehow know everything it's magical
hacking so this particular court they'll
hack into their phones and they'll hack
into their accounts especially with
intimate partner of victimization it's
easy to hack them okay and so this sort
of brings up connotations of you know
deep cyber type of stuff and maybe
you're doing software exploits or
injection or privilege escalation or
rootkits and in our data this is really
actually not the case okay so this is
not the hacking that was going on in
reality what we saw is that most of
these attacks were not technically
sophisticated okay they were done by
leveraging social knowledge of the
victim or physical proximity to the
device and the victim to be able to gain
that access okay and we define these
abusers then as something that we call
you I bound adversaries and again our
Chi paper talks about this threat model
in detail but a UI bond adversary is
essentially somebody who is bound by the
capabilities provided by the standard UI
so they're not kind of going under the
hood and and doing software exploits or
running scripts that are going to do
strange things to your device they're
literally just looking at your account
clicking on your security passwords
changing that and interacting with the
exist
ding functionality provided by that user
interface ok so they're authenticated
adversarial users of a system
authenticated means that they've
actually legitimately logged in using
the username and password or some other
access mechanism they're authenticated
but they're not the legitimate user of
that device so there's somebody else
who's compromised your account or
compromised your device but they only
interact with that via the standard user
interface not by doing anything deeper
technical level so what can we do then
about trying to combat some of these
attacks that these UI bound adversaries
are going into and this is actually
probably where we'll be focusing quite a
lot of our work over the next year or
two is trying to design tools that
account for this sort of adversary yeah
there's several layers to your question
so one is are the victims using
two-factor authentication themselves
usually the answer would be no where
two-factor authentication
did come up in our data was more that
the abuser would activate two-factor
authentication with their own phone or
their own email account so that if you
as a victim tried to change your
password it would notify them and they
would have to sign you know they would
be able to prevent you from doing that
because they were the the second factor
on that but we did not actually see
victims using two-factor authentication
very much in their own accounts and
certainly I think I'll talk about this
in a second they overwhelmingly feel
that they lack technical knowledge for
what that is and didn't know what to
factor authentication was in large part
good question other questions please do
interrupt me if I didn't see your hand
up he'll wave at me
okay so we've started thinking about how
to deal with some of these things and
some of this is going to be deliberately
a little bit vague because of time and
and the amount of stuff that I want to
talk about so this one idea we've been
thinking of that we call adversary aware
HCI so how do we design user interfaces
that automatically take into account
IPV situations okay so can we actually
degrade the abused ability of an
interface just by thinking about this
model right so if you imagine that
you're designing a user interface and
you're gonna automatically put a running
feed of the last coffee shop you were at
or the last place that you ate dinner
you might elect not to include that
feature because that's gonna give
anybody who looks at your phone the
ability to see where you were and see
what you were doing okay so this idea
that by thinking about the information
that you include in your user interface
and whether or not that's actually
necessary for what it is that you're
trying to do whether or not it might
increase the abused ability of it
without actually increasing the
usability for the legitimate user okay
another one is how to perform IPV safety
reviews for product features so this
might be something similar to
penetration testing for those of you
that are familiar with it but can we go
through a review process in which we for
every product that we're going to
release look at how this might play out
in this particular threat model and try
and design features around that
okay another idea is to try and actually
detect technically when the person using
the account is the abuser versus the
legitimate user okay so can we
distinguish between abuser login
sessions and client login sessions does
the abuser do different things when they
log in right intuitively if I log in to
my own Facebook account and I look at
some things I like a few
things right and if somebody else-- logs
into my facebook account for the
purposes of surveilling me they might
immediately go and read all of my
messages they might scroll back in my
history to see what I was doing in the
past and we might be able to detect when
those youth usage patterns are different
from what a legitimate user might do and
somehow flag those sessions either for
the legitimate user or for the
technology company and do a better job
of at least understanding when this is
going on okay our CCW paper gets into a
little bit more around how people are
already trying to deal with these
challenges okay so how are they trying
to think about tech problems at the
moment this is the ecosystem of services
that we discovered through our fieldwork
so there's all of these different
services the gray box is everything
provided by the family justice centers
that we worked with most people end up
there through a referral either from the
police or because they ended up in the
hospital in all of these things at
there's 23 different organizations at
the family justice center that provides
services ok anyone want to guess the
number of technologists zero not one not
one person who understood technology or
had the computer science background or
any of that and at the same time there
were really no best practices for
evaluating technology risks so when
somebody comes in and says they're
having all of these technology problems
there are no standard assessments there
are no standard questions there there
are no standards for safety planning
around that ok so there's a huge
opportunity to make a difference in some
of this space both victims and
professionals universally felt that they
lacked the necessary expertise to deal
with technology
okay so victims sort of said we don't
know what to do abusers were usually
considered to be more tech savvy than
the victims they would often say he's
the one that knows about the computers
he's the one that bought the devices
he's the one that set up the home
I don't know anything about that
professionals overwhelmingly also said
that they did not understand technology
sufficiently to be able to deal with the
things that were coming up with their
clients and this particular quote gets
at some of it so she said I get most of
my safety tip sheets from the nna TV
which is the national network to end
domestic violence the safety net project
which has a little section on technology
safety tips so if they have something
about what my client is experiencing
that's great but if they don't then
we're kind of trying to figure it out
and so I'm googling around to try and
understand what's going on and this was
another great thing that came up a lot
that we termed Google as you go the
client would come in they would report
something weird going on and the
professional would turn to a search
engine and just start typing in stuff to
try and understand what was happening
existing tech advice like that provided
by the safety net project or the nn adv
tends to be very high level in general
so this this is the the safety and
privacy recommendation that they have
which says you can choose who sees your
Facebook activity by setting a default
setting under privacy settings slash who
can see my stuff okay so this is the
advice that both professionals and
clients are getting for how to go
control your privacy settings okay but
in most of our setting most of our
sessions the victims would actually ask
us how to get to their privacy settings
where where are these privacy settings
how do I get there how do I find them so
this advice is at too high of a level to
actually be actionable
okay so actionable advice would
hopefully suggest an easy course of
action that they can take and have
sufficient detail for them to be able to
act on it okay and this is just at the
moment it does not exist all of it is
very high level it's obviously easier
said than done right this idea of trying
to create tutorials or information that
self updates every time Facebook
releases a different privacy setting or
updates their accounts let alone for
every tech
nology every social media platform that
the clients might use it's probably
gonna be a really hard problem to try
and deal with how to keep this these
actionable advice up to date they also
reported a lot of challenges in trying
to report abuse so both of both the
victims and the advocates would sort of
say we need a way to report the stuff we
need a way to get the technology
companies to take it down flag abuser
accounts ask for abusive content to be
removed professionals that we spoke to
said that some of the companies are
doing a reasonable job of this so
Facebook Instagram sort of came up as
ones that will actually listen if the
professionals get in touch with them but
there's a long long long tail of
uncooperative sites that either never
respond or just say that they can't do
anything about that particular content
and this is when the professional is the
one actually doing the reporting so this
is when I'm an NYPD officer getting in
touch with Facebook to ask that this be
taken down and most of these companies
are still just completely ignoring those
requests and can legally do so clients
definitely were frustrated when they
tried to report it themselves usually
they were just ignored they had trouble
finding out how to report that abuse the
nature of it and trying to get the
results that they wanted which was
usually either getting that account
deactivated getting that content taken
down okay so this client said and even
when you press something and say that
you want to report this for
offensiveness or abusiveness they don't
do anything about it and to a large
extent this is because the clients are
not the ones who own these abusive
accounts so they're actually asking for
somebody else's account to be deleted
and most of the companies are very very
hesitant to take that kind of action
because they don't necessarily believe
or know that it's an abusive account so
definitely there's a lot to be done in
that space in terms of developing both
legal and policy actions and and things
that can be done
the police officers raised a ton of
legal complications and the law in
general I think is very very far behind
the technology abuse that's actually
happening so this police officer told us
you have to figure out how to tie it all
together
besides the Facebook because if you
don't have an order of protection he's
not violating so he's just harassing
which is then not something you can get
an order of protection against that's
when I ask the other questions and then
maybe we can tie it to stalking so then
she can get an order of protection so
what's going on here is that the police
officer is trying to work with this
client to turn what she's experiencing
into something that's severe enough or
reportedly severe enough that she can
get an order of protection and in many
cases simple online harassment is not
sufficient and so they're trying to tie
it to other actions or other things that
might be going on that might rise to the
level of being able to get an order of
protection okay
of course clients really don't
understand why or why not something
might be good enough and they're
experiencing the pain of it themselves
so they're usually pretty upset about
this so abuse on Facebook or other
social media sites are not recognized as
actual abuse by the law they're not
taken into account when the judge is
determining an order of protection or
not it's still not considered to be
actually contacting someone if you're
contacting them over social media
in a lot of these settings and orders of
protection can sort of legally restricts
abusers from sending these types of
messages but usually what happens then
is that they just create a fake account
and do it from that undetectable fake
account so the ability to be anonymous
online is exacerbating a lot of these
different issues another issue is this
idea of sort of fake accounts right so
the abuser made a fake tinder account
and put up some really horrible explicit
things and she was having tons like
upwards of 25 people a night ringing her
doorbell the abuser was corresponding
with these people that wanted
hook up as if it was the client so in
this case the abuser created a tinder
account put a lot of photos on this
tinder account of that victim and
started saying that she was available
for sex and giving out her address and
you should just go over and she'll have
sex with you and she was having people
show up at her doorstep at 4:00 in the
morning and she had small children in
her house
and a lot of this can be very legally
challenging to remove okay so these sort
of come rape me style ads which is how
one police officer put it they're
actually legally paid for so if you've
paid for that ad the company that you've
paid doesn't want to take it down and so
you can report it you can report what's
happening but the company still won't
take down these ads because it's not
legally a problem so that's kind of a
whirlwind tour of some of the challenges
that we've discovered so just to recap
the use of technology and intimate
partner violence is very widespread and
often gets around our existing security
mechanism so we need to really think
about how to redesign or rethink about
some of the standard security mechanisms
to take this threat into account support
services really struggle to deal with
tech problems in part because they don't
have any technology expertise to
understand what's going on clients
really struggle to get help with
technology problems that they're
experiencing and companies and the law
are very spotty in terms of being able
to do anything about it so really it's a
little bit of a Wild West situation out
there at the moment so I can stop there
if there's lots of questions I have
about a few more slides on our spyware
study if you're interested in that but
we can also just have a discussion if
you prefer other questions hi it's
pretty alarming that the police and the
social workers were the first people
these guys went to when they had like
technology problems like they literally
like not to know anybody who can
show them how to configure crisis and
settings yes so many of them did not
have anybody who could show them that
and for many of them the person who
would show them that would be the person
who's abusing them and a lot of these
situations for example the victim might
be somebody who was brought here from
another country you know essentially
told by their abuser that if they come
to America that they're gonna have a
better life there alone in the country
they're totally controlled by that
abuser and all of their support systems
are back home so it's not to say that
across the board there's there aren't
people who would ask them but certainly
there's a large percentage for whom they
wouldn't know where to go anyone have
bright ideas for what we should do about
it I mean we have a lot of a lot of
ongoing work yes first of all very very
happy you're doing it in particular I
feel like it's very good to kind of get
out of our own bubbles and realize that
there are people sort of social worlds
and it seems like you know obviously
it's tricky some of the solutions that
you propose could also be flipped around
so it would be the user might
impersonate the victim saying oh yeah
and I'm very glad you're kind of honest
and thinking it through I was wondering
that on the legal side if the reason
that these platforms give is because
their platforms and so they kind of try
to stay they don't want to be liable for
the content on them and if they yeah I
don't know I don't know if that plays it
I just wanted to see if that was the
reasoning that you've heard from these
companies or
maybe not yes certainly a lot of it is
around their legal concerns and a lot of
it is around proof that you know online
services make it really easy to be
anonymous and they can't you can't prove
that it's them and you you know from
their perspective yes you could be
anybody requesting that any account be
deleted and so I think trying to come up
with ways that are potentially a little
bit more granular so the idea that you
would have trusted sources so maybe if
the request is coming from someone at
the uctv a caseworker or an NYPD source
that you know you might trust it more
than a random person just reporting a
random account online but certainly I
think it's a complicated problem that
there's no easy answers but I still
think we can probably be doing better
than we are certainly some as I
mentioned some of the bigger companies
seem to be doing a better job of this
and in particular Facebook and Instagram
where two of the companies that would
actually listen and engage with this
issue
many of them the other companies would
just never respond never address it and
it just would not you know there's no
dialogue at all and clients don't
understand why so I think for that
particular case there's going to have to
be some legal reason for them to
actually do that as there has been
recently with the revenge porn issue
it's now a crime at least in New York
I'm not sure about California to post
revenge porn which was a long time
coming and a big struggle to try and
actually make that the case so I think
some of this other stuff is just gonna
have to hopefully follow similar kinds
of processes or try and make it so that
you can better identify who's actually
doing some of this stuff and have a
stronger case for saying this is the
person I say it is I have a case for
getting it removed yeah
so in terms of prevention you mentioned
you know how do we forecaster predicting
may happen I'm wondering how much of
this goes to like legal normal legal
channels and how much it doesn't because
I've been interacting a lot with a legal
design lab here Margaret Hagen she's
trying to find ways of where you can use
technology to basically improve their
life the legal accessibility of a lot of
people and we have never discussed this
problem I'm thinking like you know if
they already go through like let's say
some kind of like process legal process
maybe part of the intervention that they
can provide us to support of the privacy
technology privacy setting or something
well I still would like to know how much
of this comes through like a more formal
channel and how much just never yeah so
that's a really interesting question and
I think in a lot of ways our data set is
quite biased because we're already
studying people who have made their way
to this Family Justice Center so there's
a couple things right one they have had
to acknowledge that they are an abuse
victim just to show up and get services
at these places and so there's probably
a huge number of people who are being
abused in some way who might not have
the means or the desire to come forward
who might not be aware that they're
being abused who might be in denial and
so how they're experiencing this is
something that we don't really know and
so the people that we've talked to for
the most part definitely have access to
legal services through the family
justice centers and I think that you
could tie in some of the the actions you
could take to those legal services but
obviously the people that are not
showing up at these centers or shelters
or you know within the system formally
might not have access to those formal
legal structures that said that the
lawyers themselves struggle a lot with
how to prove this stuff in court how to
get it recognized a lot of the judges
are older less technically knowledgeable
themselves and so you get into things
like a doxxing attack or a spoofing
attack and the judge doesn't understand
what spoofing is and it gets very hard
to sort of keep track of what's going on
within that legal structure so I think I
mean I think hopefully you can improve
the technical understanding within the
legal system and within policy in
general but also kind of try and have
more technical mechanisms that are
potentially developed by some of these
companies or by researchers that
intrinsically try and do this it's a
very complicated space yes relationship
between like the physical like real
world abuse versus the upon line stuff
like do they kind of replace each other
like like like if like if you take away
a person's ability to abuse their thing
online will they start using that in
person or like mmhmm yes I think I think
there's a couple things to say about
that so definitely as that we saw even
with the variety of Technology abuse is
happening simultaneously the other types
of abuse so emotional abuse verbal abuse
physical abuse sexual abuse also happen
in conjunction with technology abuse
there were a couple of common cases we
saw and again not everyone but some of
the more common things that came up were
that the abuse would be more physical
and emotional up until the point at
which the victim managed to remove
herself physically from the relationship
and then it would become digital so then
the abuser would go out and would find
you know stalk you online find ways to
get at you go and talk to your friends
and family to try and be able to you
know and a lot of people were
essentially doing you know going into
hiding and trying to essentially like
witness protection style secrecy and the
abusers doing everything they can to try
and find out where you are and what
you're doing and a lot of that becomes
then digital digitally related certainly
the harassment of our technology would
increase a lot with that physical
removal but then yes conversely if you
take that away
and you shut down the ability of that
abuser to have online access or
surveillance of the victim they would
often escalate back to physical abuse
and that was when the greatest danger is
often identified so the idea that when
is this going to result in a murder when
is it can actually result in severe
physical harm that loss of control that
escalation is usually the point at which
caseworkers and social workers are
extremely worried about the safety of
that person so in trying to deal with
some of these things it's not the case
that you can just sort of say oh we
understand you know your iCloud account
is being synced and he knows your
location and so we can just shut it down
because that could actually result in
worse outcomes and so trying to safety
plan around some of this stuff trying to
understand how they're getting access
what that access is providing is a very
complex thing to try and deal with yes
to essentially basically what you're
saying is that they have maybe more
technical expertise than the victim but
maybe not so much so for example making
it possible for it to appear as if you
know the person hadn't changed their
password or like enjoy reading
essentially sort of auto-generating
behavior so that they can't tell us
change right it's they don't have the
sophistication to figure stuff out so
you can sort of right yeah I think
that's a really interesting idea one
thing we've thought about a little bit
is if you could use up things like honey
pots for example to detect when that
person so you know there's an unread
message from someone in your facebook
and you don't read it and if somebody
goes and reads it you can assume that
it's somebody who's hacked into your
account type of situation but I think
the idea also of lying to some of these
tools that are doing the surveillance so
can you just replace that
sensor stream with you know telling them
your location is somewhere else telling
them that your camera is taking these
benign photos instead of what you're
actually taking but I think the idea of
sort of faking out the abuser so you're
saying that you would sort of you would
change your password but if somebody
tried to log in with your old password
it would show them like a benign version
of you're a fake yeah that's a great
idea maybe certain things I think that's
that's absolutely a good idea and this
idea that you could have on various
social media sites almost just like a
checkbox of I'm a victim of intimate
partner violence and it would
potentially have some way of setting
your privacy to automatically the
minimal version so that people cannot
discover you online
potentially doing a few other things
that might you might be able to either
say or that you know you could go
through a design process of what is the
minimal set of stuff that you would want
and what is the stuff that is perhaps
there now by default that you would just
hide which gets into some of that sort
of adverse area where stuff that we were
talking about trolling the community and
if you ban them then they just create a
new account and get more angry if you
shadow ban them it doesn't actually
explicitly appear to them as if anything
has happened right but the only other
people who can see their accounts or
other people have been shadowed ban so
you're sort of letting the trolls piss
on each other but without you know
without affecting the sort of non banned
users yeah I'm trying to think about
whether there are ways to do this if the
person is really not that sophisticated
it may be possible I've said anything to
sort of do a shadow ban of course I
think it then becomes possible typical
thing we're like funding user I can shut
up and new and now I can be posting
stuff using your
maybe you wouldn't see it like we'd have
to think about it yeah there's a lot of
that and I think I think you someone
said this earlier but yeah this idea
that that almost everything you think of
you have to try and think of it both
ways and it definitely happens both ways
and and this idea of sort of mutual
abuse it's very common for abusers to
have as a tactic that they're claiming
that they're the abused one and
facilitating evidence of abuse in the
other direction through spoofing tools
or whatever so it's certainly a scenario
that you would have to think about but I
think that you could probably do it in
some interesting ways that I think
that's a great idea
now what would be the risk of the person
discovers this thing right because
difference that here the reason seem so
close that they might actually go each
other
yes I think I think the you know with
the way that safety planning is done now
is very dependent off and on whether or
not you're still at least physically
present in that relationship versus you
have managed to leave that as I said
because of children and custody issues
and there's often at least some
communication but it's not the same as
you're living in the same apartment so I
think and and even now with regard to
physical safety and and all of the
safety planning that's already done the
actions and recommendations for people
when they're still in that relationship
versus they've left are very very
different and so you could potentially
think about that as being a separation
of models you know another idea that was
that we've been floating around is this
idea that you would sort of have
multiple versions of your account and if
someone's forcing you to hand over your
password you know one password reveals
benign looking account another password
would reveal your actual personal data
and so you could potentially give your
abuser access to the account that you
have created for that there's always a
risk of
detection and trying to balance that at
the moment the way this is done is it's
up to the client to do what they feel
comfortable with and so you just try and
explain the risks and the potential for
things to happen and they make the
choice for themselves how that actually
plays out legally in terms of liability
or how we would take responsibility as
designers or HCI or Technology people
building these tools is a little unclear
at this point for whether or not you
create something that shows them a fake
account and they discover that and kill
their victim are you responsible for
that either
you know ethically morally or legally I
think is something that requires a lot
of thought
[Applause]
you